today we're gonna take questions from
people who are chatting in online and I
want to get started just by asking each
of you to briefly introduce yourselves
yeah and talk a little bit about your
background what were you doing before
you applied to the Stanford MBA program
and what ultimately led you to pursue an
MBA at Stanford sure I can start so my
name is Sarah I graduated in 2010
studied economics from Chicago
originally and before the GSB I had
tried two things first
worked in the capital markets on the
banking side at Morgan Stanley and then
moved over to consulting and was a with
BCG for three years the reason I decided
to apply to the business school and to
Business School in general and also the
GSB was I really wanted to get into
impact investing and it was something
that I didn't really see a path toward
and also wanted to explore before I
really dedicated myself to it and so
have gotten do so well here and I worked
for a few years in consulting tears than
consulting in Atlanta and then worked
for four years in social enterprise in
sub-saharan Africa primarily within
operations roles what made me most
interested about wanting to come back to
GSB and MBA was I was interested in
moving back to the states and the MBA
seem like a very good way to move back
stateside and then I was interested in
developing skills beyond kind of core
operations and supply chain skills
specifically within leadership and
general strategy awesome that's really
interesting
so we've got a few questions that have
been sent to us already via chat um
somebody is asking us what are the most
common careers that Stanford MBAs pursue
after you graduate and I know this is a
really personal question so maybe each
of you can just talk about what were
your career goal is coming into Stanford
and what are you planning to do after
you graduate and what are some of the
resources that you're using at Stanford
to help you navigate that path so coming
into Stanford I was very interested in
working with in entrepreneurship and a
startup probably specifically within a
social enterprise space again
over my time here I pivoted a little bit
more to being interested in health care
and upon graduation I'll be working with
a very large medical device company an
emerging market strategy so kind of
combining two of those together the
resources I used we're on campus
recruiting which happens both in first
year and second year and I actually
ended up taking a full time offer with
the firm I interned with this summer but
before doing that before accepting that
offer I also considered consulting also
there on campus recruiting and then one
or two other opportunities that came
through with speaking with other alumni
that were also working in the health
healthcare space and I mentioned that I
was interested in testing my thesis on
impact investing and so to do that the
GSB has a resource called impact labs
the impact labs program and so I got to
apply an intern for an impact investment
fund which was exactly what I wanted to
do and got to work at a fund during the
year tested that out and actually
realized that I wanted to try more
traditional early-stage wresting
investing after that I wasn't really
sure how impact investing was defined at
least in my mind so through a summer
internship tried traditional venture
capital really enjoyed that will will
likely also be returning to my summer
internship and would say I think
resources that were helpful along the
way for me also took advantage of our
alum Network in terms of just learning
about what they do
I'm helping recruiting and then our
career management office is was really
great too had a lot of one-on-one
sessions with our career advisors and
and they really helped me hone in on
what I was interested in and what I
wanted to do great we also have a
question about global experiences I just
talked earlier about the requirement as
well as the portfolio of opportunities
that are available could each of you
share kind of what your global
experiences look like and what the
experience was like for you sure um so
last year I went on two of the trips
that the GST s that were type of the
global study trips my first one was in
the winter to Thailand and then my
second was to South Africa and I would
say both of them were incredible I
hadn't been to either of those countries
and the trips really help you learn
about the country there's a big cultural
component that goes into just learning
about the food and some of the customs
you have to do meetings beforehand which
were really helpful and you know hitting
the ground and knowing what to to do and
not feeling like a total outsider and
then I also just loved getting to know
these very different economies and yeah
there's a sovereign nation in Thailand
that we had to think about learning
about agriculture there was really
fascinating and those are probably two
of my favorite experiences at the GSB in
the first year and I did trip over
spring break to go to Brazil and it was
specifically a social innovation trip
focused on health and education in
Brazil so likewise to Sarah and there's
just so much that you could learn there
what I really liked about it was we met
from everyone from the former president
of Brazil during during a financial
crisis that was going on in the country
all the way through to a frontline
clinic in the northeast of the country
so kind of getting and everything in
between so wide breadth of experiences
the other thing I would add is it's such
an amazing opportunity to really are
another amazing opportunity to really
get to know your classmates well and
twenty people are on the trip and you're
spending ten days with them and a lot of
time in each of those days and so it's
another great opportunity to build
relationships within the within the
community here great
so pivoting a little bit to the campus
experience did either of you have a
significant other or has a significant
other and can you talk a little bit
about the experience of coming to the
GSB with a partner sure yeah so my
experiences of maybe might be a little
bit different I my boyfriend is also a
student and Nick in my class I'm also an
MBA - currently and so it's you know I
think the first time that we were in
school together I think I would
definitely say it's it's tough because
as probably everyone's heard it's it can
get really busy so it's important to set
side time with one another but I think
for us you know we really viewed and I
think this is true for even couples
where one person is a student one person
is not it's really a mutual growing
experience and there's so many
opportunities for your partner to be
involved or not involved depending on
what kind of path you decide to carve
and it can be a huge learning experience
for both of you whether you're both
students or not and so I don't have an S
over while being here but I will add
there are a lot of other resources that
are available there are there's actually
clubs for eso's and you get integrated
within the campus so you're also
actually gets a card to go to the gym
and the sporting events that are here
and then even some of the most popular
classes within the GSB you're also can
take within their own sections so for
example touchy feely is a really well
known course here and they have special
sections for us so so I think there's a
lot of effort to culturally integrate
them into the community so it's kind of
one large class we also have a question
about financially Aidan is it offered to
international students so I can actually
take that one because they don't think
either of you or international students
but I we do offer need-based financial
aid for every single person who's
admitted to our program and we don't
differentiate between international
students or American students in terms
of access to financial aid but maybe
each of you could speak a little bit
about the cost benefit thoughts that
went through your mind when you were
pursuing an MBA and ways that you
financed it or thought about investing
in your education here at Stanford so I
came from a background of having done
four years of living and working in
sub-saharan Africa so I was a recipient
of some of the need-based financial aid
which very much made that a positive NPV
calculation for me it's amazing about
how much recruiters start coming to you
as a GSB student all the way through
on-campus recruiting to just random kind
of cold emails that happen during your
second year so the the bump in in salary
can be pretty significant and more
importantly maybe the salary but the
actual opportunities that you can do
well in some of these organizations
makes it MPD product positive I mean for
me within one or two
yeah I think for me I didn't receive
substantial fellowship actually very low
and have been relying primarily on loans
and so I think that cost benefit for me
it's actually still you know the benefit
is harder to measure at least in the
near term but for me the GSB has opened
up doors as Nick mentioned that I just
would never been able to walk through
before coming or even knowing that I
wanted to and I think before coming in
there was you know honestly a question
my mind of this is expensive you know
consulting is also general you can go to
something else and I think having this
hindsight bias now I'm really glad that
I did make that trade-off and I just
want to say too if you're not a
fellowship recipient the school and also
there are private resources are that are
both are really good and helping you
bridge that gap and it's what I rely on
for for my education great so aside from
great whether someone is asking us what
are some of the benefits of our location
where we are either geopolitically or in
terms of the valley
have you taken advantage of local
resources that are around campus from a
lifestyle perspective I love hiking and
if you haven't had a chance to come to
the bay and figure out like what
redwoods are they're these massive trees
some of the most beautiful hiking I
think in the world in terms of day hikes
are right around here San Francisco is
an amazing city just culturally it's
great Silicon Valley so I think the
benefit of the school is we get a lot of
entrepreneurs and venture capitalists
that come in to speak and teach classes
here that you probably wouldn't get
outside of the valley just cuz the
resources that are here yeah I would say
make pretty much covered it and just add
that for a lot of industries like
venture capital which I'm interested in
also tech but many more a health care
consumer there are so many interests
interesting exciting companies within an
hour drive of us and so I think getting
to visit them whether that's through
interviews or just learning has been
really
and you're kind of in the middle of it
so I would say something less tangible
is just the energy that you get from
that and you know I grew up in Chicago
went to school in Boston lived in New
York I do think it's pretty unique to
this area skiing and surfing is also
really accessible if you're in the
morning surf in the afternoon so along
the same lines having access to all of
these companies do you have any concrete
examples you really wanted to explore
impact investing and we have a question
about access to social entrepreneurship
and having been previously involved in
kind of social impact related work do
you have any thoughts on resources for
that in particular either within the
region or at in the Stanford MBA program
each one of you could touch briefly yeah
so I think you know I briefly mentioned
this before but I think the impact in
bet both impact investing and then also
just impact labs program is a program
offered by the GSB where you're placed
either with a nonprofit or an impact
investment fund and you get to intern
for them for school credit I would also
say more generally this that Social
Innovation is very very well resourced
at the GSB and at Stanford broadly so
there's a social innovation Club a
student Club but they're also you know
resources at the center that you can
take advantage of to test different
hypotheses that you want to so just add
on that the Center for Social Innovation
actually has GSB staff on that they have
trips of GST global study trips that
will focus specifically on Social
Innovation I was on one in Brazil and
then there's another program called seed
which has an acronym that I don't know
what it stands for but essentially is
money that's set aside to invest with
social entrepreneurs and that that
materializes a few ways from a student
experience so one is a lot of times
those social entrepreneurs from around
the world will be here on campus and you
have access to them and then secondly to
that there's a chance to to take funding
to work in social entrepreneurship as
part of your internship experience so if
an organization kind of can qualify
through stand
to accept funding it allows you to get
closer to market rate as a student to
work in social entrepreneurship over the
summer and then also they have a loan
forgiveness program to certain students
should you launch a career with a
non-profit and social entrepreneur
afterwards so I think there are lots of
lots of access and lots of resources and
I argue probably one of the core
competencies in the school there's
really concrete examples so tom has a
question for you guys about aspects of
your experience where you may have been
challenged beyond what you expected at
the GSB and what is the most important
piece of advice that you would give your
first year self looking back now so yeah
so I think the first thing is is be open
and ready to change so one of the the
great parts of the curriculum here have
to do a lot with interpersonal skills
and leadership development there are so
many mental models or there were so many
mental models that I held coming into
the GSB about what leadership is how
people react in different situations and
being in such a diverse environment and
having a very open culture of feedback
and the way the curriculum is set up you
really get to channel challenge those
mental models and I think some of the
most challenging parts were in a team
situation or in some of these courses
where you kind of really get down to
being having to be pretty vulnerable to
get to a point to get changed and become
a much more effective leader and so
being open to that process is really
really important and sometimes can take
a few weeks to get comfortable in yeah I
would think um sort of along this the
same theme before the GSB I wouldn't
consider myself a leader I was very good
at getting the job that was asking me
done and always at a junior level as an
analyst or associate and at the GSB it's
the first time I've ever in my life felt
like I have the confidence to be a
leader and I think that's actually been
associated with things that have been
challenging at the GSB so I'm one of the
co presidents of women and management
this year and helped lead a board of 10
people we plan retreats for the full
class and just thinking about thing
like how do you create a bored culture
how do you motivate people who are
volunteers and your friends but need to
get a lot of work done um you know among
our already busy schedule and I think
those are real things that managers and
leaders have to face and I've never
gotten the opportunity to do so and have
just learned so much from that
experience I think my advice to my first
year cell for any first years would be
be open like Nick said but also just
take the chance and have confidence in
yourself and I think having confidence
sometimes just comes from doing it
anyway even if you think you can't do it
and asking yourself why not you and I
think the GSB has made me ask myself
that over and over again and I've just
taken on way more than I would have
thought I could have that's not only
great advice or first year but probably
great advice for life so you touched a
little bit about the challenges of being
a club leader balancing that with a lot
of other obligations at school so we've
got a question about a typical week how
are you balancing cut and dry classwork
leadership opportunities through clubs
other you know initiatives that you
might be involved with how does that
break down and how do you end up
prioritizing your time sure so I guess
I'll preface of this with I was given
the advice and I haven't followed as
closely they should have but it's
definitely good advice to ruthlessly
prioritize and do that by coming in and
obviously being adaptive I'm inflexible
but coming in with a clear list of what
your prior priorities are and whether
that's academics or social job-related
being pretty specific about them just
coming in because I think a big struggle
at least for me at the GSB is not
letting the urgent get in the way of the
important so I would say the topic of
time management has been has been tough
for me because there are so many
interesting things to do here
in terms of a typical week and this kind
of ties back to my priorities which I
think number one were around meeting
people that's one of the big reasons I
came here just to get to experience the
people here
and then I would say for me and this I
might be a minority here but academics
are really important to me and I I love
I loved the classes that I've been in
and the professors that I've had so I
would say spent a fair amount of time on
academics and then you know I mentioned
women in management and a few other
extracurriculars and I'm in I would say
I pretty much spread my time among those
three and right now for me at least
extracurriculars are taking a bigger
role in my life I think for
prioritization I try to go back to my
list that I created and you know update
every now and then to say I said that
this is more important to me let me not
cancel on a meeting with a friend
because of this particular thing which
you know I know is less important and
yeah I'm trying to think about also how
that changed my first year - my second
year so first year I think academics
probably require a little bit more work
outside of the classroom then they do
your second year in your second year you
have all electives so also because
you're you've chosen every single class
you want to be in working for them
doesn't really feel like work it's it's
you know intellectually stimulating on
all levels and so I probably I don't
know could give an hour breakdown but
you know there is a decent amount of
time for a class prep meeting other
classmates and building relationships
with classmates to take a significant
amount of time but I mean that's
something I love doing I also need a lot
of personal time for myself so I block
out at least an hour a day just a that's
on my calendar that no one else can can
schedule over and so I there's kind of
there's a great way to balance academics
recruiting recruiting takes up a lot of
time depending which cycle you go
through and then you have just
prioritize at what quarter which of
those are most important for you to go
through have you thought about pursuing
a joint or dual degree I have not I
thought about doing the Masters of
Education okay
and I decided against it only just
because I mean and the reason I wanted
to do it was so that I could get an
extra quarter so I could get two
internships
and that really just kind of came back
to prioritizing because I was kind of
thinking did I want to do health or
education and just did kind of a
cost-benefit analysis and decided
against it yeah but we have obviously
lots of classmates that are doing JD MBA
s that we're doing MD MBAs and they seem
to really enjoy it
yeah and it's an important personal
calculus to make just like everything
else at the GSB it's kind of a
choose-your-own-adventure and you always
need to think through the trade-offs if
what do I gain from this and what are
the advantages of doing it or not doing
it did you dip your toes into the water
of maybe taking classes at the ad school
or have either of you taken classes what
we call across the street any of the
other grad schools at Stanford I am I
have not yet I'm hoping next quarter to
take what's called bio design which I
think it is actually a med school class
but it's cross-functional between
engineering medicine and business to
launch a medical device product yeah I
would say I'm in the same camp I've just
found there to be so many interesting
GSB classes that being said though
something that I came in really wanting
to get a better grasp of is computer
science and obviously Stanford is one of
the best computer science programs in
the world and so for next quarter I'm
signed up for a computer science class
and I think something that I would also
like to try is just more with the design
school which I think has that very
unique type of thinking then we can all
benefit from great I'm also taking rock
climbing next quarter I forgot to throw
that in there so there are lots of PE
classes that are everything from hip-hop
to rock climbing to horseback riding to
golf golf as a very very popular sunny
all the time here so I've gotten a few
questions for admission so I'm just
gonna address those really quickly one
was for students who apply from college
directly so if you're currently a senior
in college you're more than welcome to
apply to you go through the exact same
application process and you actually
we're looking for the same three
criteria that we talked about earlier in
the presentation so we're not looking
for anything different if you're
thinking about letters of recommendation
you might want to think about your
summer internships
faculty members tend not to be the best
recommenders in our view we're looking
for people who really can highlight your
professional competencies as well as
your leadership so if a professor was an
advisor to you for a club for example or
for your research that would be really
helpful but if it was just a
student-teacher relationship typically
that's where I see college seniors
benefiting more from using your
internship supervisors or you know other
people that have you've kind of been
held accountable to once you get in we
typically ask you to defer your
enrollment so you actually go and get
some work experience for a couple years
and then matriculate into the GSB after
those two or two years in terms of
making yourself competitive as an
undergrad the same advice actually goes
to everybody which is and you know we
are looking for people that demonstrate
a lot of intellectual curiosity so take
tough classes challenge yourself perform
well and then get involved in activities
in your community and demonstrate your
leadership potential those are things
we're looking for across all of our
candidates
similarly for joint and dual degree
programs we're not looking for any
separate admissions criteria we're
looking for the same three things for
our program however you will also have
to meet the admissions requirements for
those other programs so whatever the
requirements are say for law school or
medical school those are not things that
we would be looking for in our
candidates but they are things that you
would obviously have to meet for those
other programs we also had a question
about placing weight on every component
of the application itself for example do
we weigh the GPA versus test versus
recommendation letters differently and I
wish I could tell you that there was
some secret formula for how to read an
application and create a calculus for it
it would make my job way easier but
actually it's an art and a science so we
don't have any sort of equation that we
use so by definition there is no weight
placed on any one component we talked a
little bit earlier about how we have
holistic application process and what
that means fundamentally is that we look
at every single piece of your
application so every single thing counts
and everything is a part of our review
process we try to weave all three
criteria of intellect leadership and
personal qualities into our evaluation
of you as a candidate and we really pour
a lot of time and energy and
appreciation for how much you invest in
your application by taking a holistic
approach to it so there's no one piece
of your application that kind of makes
or breaks it even if you're invited to
interview it's not like the interview
tips you in or out that goes back in
your application which is really a 'td
as a whole so every single piece matters
and not one piece matters more than the
other so we're coming up on the last
five minutes and we had a student ask a
question that I think would be or not a
student participant asked a question
that could be a good capstone for us and
that is kind of have you had one
monumental experience so far at the GSB
and I can phrase that another way which
would be can you talk about your
favorite memory so far and it can be
anything it doesn't have to be academic
or if it is that's great but anything
about your experience that you would say
stands out as your favorite part so far
question actually I have one I have mine
I mentioned that I am co-leading women
in management this year and it's been a
really challenging experience part of
the reason that it was so challenging
was planning our annual fall retreat 160
women come together for a weekend and
really it's ours to plan we have last
year's curriculum but we decided to go
rogue this year and do it from scratch
and it was just it was incredibly
stressful the you know months leading up
to it and I would say it was the most
fulfilling moment for me at GSB because
of what happened that weekend and and
also you know just the I would
the discussions but really the sense of
community that came out of that I think
when you get to the GSB especially your
first year it's just kind of crazy and
in good ways but also not-so-great ways
and to the opportunity to provide a
retreat where for particularly first
year MBAs could hit the reset button and
say hey let's breathe let's pause and
let's remember why we came here and also
talk about what's holding us back from
being our fullest selves and really be
authentic and honest I got to facilitate
those sessions for the first time and
I'm just hearing those discussions come
out of that made all of the effort
really worth it and and I think just the
community element to inter class which I
wanted more of last year was really
special for me I think there had been a
lot of profounder impactful moments that
have happened within a lot of the
interpersonal dynamic classes and
leadership classes that I've had but
those are going to take a while to set
up so I say probably one of the more
like pinch myself moments was I was in a
class with dr. Condoleezza Rice who was
the former US Secretary of State and we
had a case simulation that she was
running about what to do from a business
standpoint you know in Eastern Europe
assuming this fictitious country invaded
this and you had resources in that
country and ended up getting into like a
very very small suit or debate about
like the tripwire theory of NATO which
was like crazy that you know this is one
of the architects for some of this and
an actual policymaker and still very
prominent on the world stage in that
side and I think that speaks a little
bit of the resources that you cut or the
access you can get in this type of
environment not happen like the third
week of class in my first year wow
that's that's really exciting well I
want to thank both of you so much for
taking the time I know we've talked
about priorities and how busy you guys
all are on campus so I just want to
thank you so much for sharing your
experience and really bringing the
Stanford MBA experience alive to
everybody who's been joining us and to
all of you who've been online with us I
really appreciate you spending your time
with us as well to learn more about the
Stanford MBA program